把那扣交給他我就可以去睡覺了
那這個他是真的能做到
所以最賺錢的也是這個公司
說實在
企業級應用啊
那你說昨天我還問那個
那個博士啊
哦
這個是Soul Max
就是5.6的這個
這個我們常用的這個
昨天我問那個高博士我說你們是在做科研
那你用每個模型啊
用P6 100是嗎
你昨天講的好像很厲害樣子
他說別傻了
我們全是用GPT 5.6的OK
因為呢
我們還是要用
在科研他說每個環節其實他都要極高的智商
去處理一些難題的啊
那相對招一個人來說這個已經是最便宜的了
你後來想一想
200美金一個月啊假設你都請
你去請個實際生都不夠
對不對
但是你用這個
你就請了幾個頂尖的工程師啊
啊
數據分析師啊等等啊
OK
好但是怎麼省Poken啊你也可以看到啊
Luna呢也是
也是GPT裡面的
硬桿利息的一個模型啊
所以你可以知道啊
比如說你意圖很清晰不用讓
呃模型去思考判斷你的意圖的
也不是很複雜的任務
其實你用低端的模型就可以解決了
用Luna Next
如果你已經把執行的那個
列表都給他了
你只是操作一下文件啊
寫一些代碼
其實用普通的就可以了
但是如果你要Grainstone
思考了寫計畫的
一個長任務的規劃的
一定要用
啊
我們粵語的
So high
Chu so high
OK啊
王先生啊
啊
所以什麼時候可以降檔啊
所以你對質量的要求高不高
對吧
你對速度
欸速度這個呢
待會不會講啊
越高推你能力的
其實是越慢的啊
再來你的成本
好這個就計費了
這個我也不用多說了
你們回去試用就感受到了啊
昨天的Webbody每個月都有送積分啊
搞笑了就說我用Codex
寫了個自動領積分的
我就可以每天都用了啊
OK
那實際上
呃呃呃你用了體感就知道啊
我一開始
也是嘗試著用20刀的
後來發現實在是
不夠用所以呢
最少要200刀起了啊
這個
模型啊
那速度呢
就這樣子啊
呃
速度可能
可能他們很多這種
這種fresh模型啊
越簡單的模型
其實它反應是越快的啊
那橫軸呢是輸入的反應啊
所以你只是問一些最基礎的問題呢
你其實用比較便宜比較快的就可以啊
好所以你這個大概就給你一個
一個概念啊
就是我到底多快多貴
你要去想這個問題
我這個任務
符不複雜要不要用複雜模型
我上下文有多少
對吧
來來去思考這個問題
去調用什麼模型
昨天我幫
補個裝完了
他全部用最貴的那個
最強的那個
對吧
兩下Token就沒了
問我怎麼Token沒了
我說你其實這麼簡單的
處理文件的任務
用剛剛那個Lunamax就可以了
好再來呢你可以
定期的去管理你的上下文啊
我講的案例全是Codex的
因為我現在比較少用的問題啊
那Codex呢就是
你要查看你現在上下文佔了多少
因為佔了越多了
你可能
廢話有點太多
它就比較貴
所以你用那個Status呢就可以看到
我現在到底佔了多少
然後如果你一個任務已經
完成完了你就可以把它壓縮一下
壓縮一下它其實現在也有自動的了
你聊著聊著它也會自動幫你壓縮的
然後其實呢Agent呢它還有個厲害的地方
它就是有自動化的一些memory的原理
它能夠記得你說過啥
知道你的慣性你在做什麼任務
它都能夠知道啊
所以能夠幫你
完成你想要的事情
那這個呢是我們待會會
比較深度講的
到底怎麼去寫一些Hardness
包括Agent也MD啊
MD又是什麼啊呀
這個待會我們會說啊
好
那時間有限我這些實操直接跳過
你們回去自己多操作
OK
好
那我們直接下一個環節
第二招呢我們講的是架構啊
那到底呢我們怎麼來選擇我們
具體的工作具體的架構啊
OK
好那簡單的來說呢你在用AI的時候啊
你不要想到什麼就用什麼你要先把這個工作講清楚了
然後呢
讓他能夠真的
創建完文件當他是你要把AI當成人
就當他是真的一個員工啊
你要給他足夠的
資料啊
誰用的呀
怎麼樣的情況下你觸發啊
到底我要最後你招交付什麼給我啊
你要跟他
盡量的說清楚啊
然後再來了你要判斷你的任務到底長什麼樣子
有很多人說啊我又想做AI
用AI做這個
又想用AI做那個
對吧
那有的又很複雜有的又
啊
沒什麼意義做出來
所以我們說呢
第一個你先考慮到你身邊有什麼
很高價值的任務
他是比較簡單的
你先把它做
練練手
對吧
然後再來呢你要做一些
系統級別的
OK
複雜度很高價值又很高的
那就不要急慢慢做
先縮小每一個小環節都給他閉環了
最後連串起來變成一個系統啊
那低價值的
也很簡單的
那你就隨便
有空的時候做一做啊
那不要去整天做一些又複雜又沒價值的
再哪一段糟糕可能是沒有太大意義的
好所以我們做了
複雜的系統啊
他不是一下子給AI就搭出來了
我們還是需要一步步的去
觀察他
避環他
審查他
最後控制他
最後才能成為真正的一個成熟系統
以前的這些工作量非常大
現在呢
你真的可以幫AI幫你
寫一個系統寫一個網上都是沒問題的
這些這些我們直接看一看就可以
因為不是什麼很複雜的事情
就是我們以
現在呢大部分的執行就是讓AI做的
我們人呢就是要做好判斷啊
授權啊給資料啊批准他呀
然後什麼時候呢這個系統啊要停止了
比如說燒太過Token了
一直卡在一個出落的點
沒辦法弄好或者是他的需求不清楚
是要把它停住啊
所以我們說呢很多時候我們做系統之前呢
就是先
這個MVP這個詞呢現在經常聽啊
就是minimum value
忘記什麼了
就是一個最小的一個
Potup
最小的一個
壁環的產品
Potup
OK
然後能壁環了
那你就能找到它
OK
講這些支持呢其實我不太在喊了
所以呢
我幹了什麼事情呢
我幹了一些很厲害的事情
我用Hunners呢做了一個
只要我發一條抖音視頻給我這個Hunners
他就能生產一條教育的視頻
OK
所以我們來看看我的Hunners做出來的視頻
找怎麼樣了
想到什麼就讓AI
我一句我只
我只跟他講了五秒鐘的話而已
然後呢
他是跟我一樣的聲音啊
是不是想到什麼就讓AI做什麼
先不要急著讓AI幹活
真正要回答的是
任務有多複雜
以及你需要多強的控制力
清任務只要快速驗證
複雜任務才需要拆分
入游
和狀態管理
七種架構不是排行榜
而是一條從Done Agent
到協作系統
再到Graph Workflow的眼鏡線
本章先記住兩個判斷軸
複雜度和控制力
後面每一種架構
都放回這張座標系列選擇
Done Agent
就是一個大模型包攬輸入
思考
調用工具和輸出
它簡單
便宜
延遲低
適合做概念驗證
和簡單對話
一旦任務變複雜
模型容易認知過載
出現上下文污染
Reactor
把過程變成
reason 加 action 的循環
思考
行動
觀察
再決定下一步
它比Done Agent更適合多度探索
也更容易解釋過程
但Token消耗大
容易跑偏
不適合直接承擔大規模生產流程
Plan and Execute
先生成完整計劃
再按步驟執行
它讓流程更穩定
適合代碼生成和長流程自動化
但計劃如果一開始就錯
後面的執行會把錯誤放大
靈活性也不如React
Multi Agent
再進一步
把任務分別不同角色
例如
Planter
Executor
Planter和Reveal
這樣上下文
邊界更清楚
複雜流程更容易擴展
代價是調用成本
協作協議和失敗處理都會增加
它適合對流程移植性要求高的行業任務
Looter加Scale的關鍵不是讓模型自由發揮
而是先讓意圖路由器選中一個Scale
再執行這項可復用能力
這樣更穩定更容易緩存
也能用命中率評估效果
代價是Scale設計成本高
還要處理路由衝突
Blackboard
則讓多個Agent共同讀寫一份共享狀態
狀態變化推動下一步執行
它適合複雜協作
但狀態模型
全線和追蹤必須先設計好
否則出了問題很難定位
Graph Workflow
用圖來編排長流程
節點代表步驟
編代表條件
它可以支持分支
並行回溯和從事
所以最適合流程自動化和生產環境
你可以把七種架構排成一條眼鏡線
Done Agent做最小驗證
React做多步探索
Plan and Execute做工程化
Dore Agent做角色協作
Rode Skill做精準技能系統
Blackboard管共享狀態
Graph Workflow承載長流程
最後用三論做選擇
任務有多複雜
哪裡必須可控
失敗後能不能重施和回滾
沒有最好的架構
只有最合適的架構
哇 講的比我好太多了
OK
這個呢就是我只用了
三個字
三件事啊
第一我找了個抖音視頻
PTT做的很好看
對吧
抖音一大堆那種視頻啊
我覺得他講的很好啊
但是我怎麼
如果我現場講啊
我講不出這種效果
說實在的
所以我就在思考
怎麼做個助教Agent出來
對吧
然後助教Agent呢
就是我先給他素材
抖音這個素材
OK 待會我會稍微講一下
我用了什麼架構來做這個助教Agent
現在呢
我這個Agent厲害到什麼程度了
我隨便發他一個
一個
三更中的視頻
不用超多少Token
就出來一個有我聲音
甚至能有我數字人啊
一個PTT動畫都做好的一個視頻
語音還是對齊的
我一個
就沒有給他任何的
複雜的操作
他就可以做出來了
那再補充一點啊
系統裡面呢
其實未來系統更值錢的是什麼
是他的一個
安全性和權限
對吧
不要有人說
哇我搞了一個系統很厲害
我要上線了
最後不是崩了
就是被人黑了
對吧
然後呢還一堆代碼不知道怎麼改過來
OK所以未來其實
你說工程師的職業會不會替代
實際上最後一個環節
怎麼能夠穩定的7x24服務
對吧
第一個穩定性
第二個安全性
會不會
兜底啊
怎麼有人太多人過載的時候
有bug了怎麼辦啊
對吧
能不能修復啊
等等等等啊
這些才是最難的工作
執行和展示
一定不是什麼難的事情啊
好所以這個呢控制點呢
就是說我們
呃
需要過程留衡啊
哪些人做過什麼操作
這個是安全性的事情
對吧
然後再來我們要有一些驗證
最後呢什麼情況下很緊急的要把站把它停機了
這些都是
工程師最後最值錢的地方
把高風險的東西留給人啊
把低風險啊
什麼固定的展示啊
呃
跟那個網頁的一些文字啊
這種低風險啊
全全交給AI就可以了
好接下來呢
就重點啊
為什麼我架構也選了
Agent 還是沒有按照我的要求
把事情做出來呢
OK
有幾個可能啊
就是你可能
目標跟邊界講的不清楚啊
然後呢
AI 也對你的意圖理解的不深
然後代碼寫的越多可能
你越要改動又要閱讀
就比較痛苦啊
那我們怎麼能夠
怎麼能夠
把這個事情做好呢
這裡呢
我們真的要去
多調用一些skills啊
這個我給大家介紹一下
但以前說啊
很多skills是需要
增留別人啊
什麼意思啊
今天如果我是一個很厲害的工程師
然後他就會
老闆就會思考了
這個人
工資又高了
怎麼把它寫成skills就可以把它裁了
對吧
我用AI 調用這個skills就可以了
但現在呢
很多skills都是開業免費的
而且做得非常好啊
像這個呢
是
Codex 裡面最厲害最厲害的一個skills啊
是我騰訊那個每個月
稍微8000刀的那個
那個介紹我用的
這個叫Superpowers
對
大家可以記憶一下
這個是
真的強大大不行
我現在用最多的就是這個skills
他是幹什麼
他其實就是一個最頂尖的一個工程師
他做的事情啊
很厲害的
比如說我要做
我今天這幾個網站啊
都是我幫他來做的
我一個字都沒有碰
我第一步
他會跟你brainstorm
跟你需求對齊
所以為什麼叫
人跟AI聊
不要跟人聊
因為他可能更懂你
你跟他brainstorm
到底你要做什麼
要寫什麼代碼
實現什麼功能
他會每一個環節都問你問題的
你要先告訴他
你有什麼目標
他就開始問你問題了
這個是這樣做嗎
你是想這樣嗎
等等等等啊
最後寫成需求表了以後
他還會去Git上面幫你創建一個項目
因為這樣你才能回退啊
或者是疊貸啊等等啊
保存啊
第三步
他會幫你寫執行計劃
第一步
我們要先把前端寫出來
然後呢
搭一個數據庫
最後呢把你的後台弄進去
你的後台有這麼多功能
我又會
創建一個
後台的agent
去幫你執行任務
壓根我一個字都沒寫
OK
然後第四步他會
創建很多個子agent
負責不同的任務
第五步厲害了
以前呢
我們做很多系統出來都是
哦
產品經理有需求
然後給到程序員
程序員寫完了
然後找到測試那邊去測的
他這個厲害了
直接幫你創建了一堆測試員
然後把你的不同環節全部測試通了
他才會交付給你
第六步呢
又有一個
COVID-19的一個過程
就是幫你看一下代碼有沒有
隆餘的呀
效率不好的呀
或者寫錯的呀
或者有更好的寫法
他都會幫你做審查
然後最後呢
幫你
發佈到不同的分支
有需要的時候再合併啊
這個也是記號上面
基本上最多信心的一個skill了
就是幫你請一個工程師到你們公司裡面去吧
但是他有個缺點是什麼
大家覺得他的缺點是什麼
這麼完善的一個skill
Token很貴
這第一個啊
第二個是
如果你一開始的需求是錯的
他幹了
六個小時後
你會發現
沒法改了
錯的離譜
就是用過一開始錯的話
就會錯的很離譜
這個老師
你講的很好
那他這第一步他用什麼
第二步用什麼
那個工具你怎麼介紹一下
呃
稍等
我待會有點會弄
OK
因為其實現在在場的呀
我覺得
我的東西是很
比較
就是如果是剛接觸AI
可能這東西都不聽不太懂
對吧
那沒有關係
我這東西啊
啊
因為我昨天做
看了一下
其實真正裝Codex的人
呃只有三五個
從前呢也只有三五個
所以其實你們的階段
可能還在為Body
和普通的工作而已
但我這東西先給你說了
你不一定馬上能用
但是過了
過了一兩個月你會發現
哇龍哥講的這個東西
才真正是AI啊
對吧
才真的是
怎麼去
怎麼去用工程化的思維
跟架構的思維去用AI
你們先解決的是你們的
手頭上的工作怎麼啼笑了
放大了
這些東西
不用
揪結現在我一個小時內就要變成工程師
不用了
你回去了
等到你真的用到的時候
你把這個BP再打開
然後上網搜一下Superpower
大家把視頻都可以教你
對
好這邊我給大家做一個小小的
小小的
演示啊
其實口袋用起來跟
跟Body差不多了
字幕志願者 李宗盛
Codex唯一厲害的跟Mamai的區別 因為我用習慣的就是因為它有很多最pop的一些SKILL還有一些NCP的一些工具 它這裏能夠直接用到 反正用的最好的很難回去就是了 對所以呢 這裡有個SuperPower那你直接就是一樣的你點擊它 你就可以安裝了免費的 安裝完了以後呢 你要調用的時候隨便創建一個
鞋桿一下就可以調用了
Supfer Power的
Supfer Power就可以看到它的功能了
不好意思